shiki's got the ball she goes for the
header she scores
so hello and welcome to the shooky
science show where in this video
we're going to look at the question can
exercise reduce
tumor growth so in particular we'll be
taking a look at this recent e-life
paper
cytotoxic t-cells mediate
exercise-induced reductions
in tumor growth also in the description
i've put a link to a pretty good review
article as well if you're interested to
learn more about this topic
and also now i know it may not look like
it but that football intro took me a
long time to make so i'd really
appreciate it if you gave this video a
like
anyway back to the question can exercise
really reduce
tumor growth well there's a wealth of
evidence that supports an association
between regular exercise
and a decreased risk for cancer and
cancer mortality
as you can see here regular moderate
vigorous physical activity is associated
with a low risk for developing several
cancers
including proximal and distal colorectal
cancer endometrial cancer
breast cancer prostate cancer and
ovarian cancer and lung cancer and also
pancreatic cancer
the world's health organization
recommends levels of 150
minutes per week of moderate to vigorous
physical activity
and it has been suggested that there
could even be a data response pattern
whereby in one study they saw that the
maximal benefit
or physical activity against total
cancer risk was approximately twice the
minimum
world's health organization
recommendation and so the major question
that this raises is how does exercise
achieve this
and the reason that this is such an
interesting question is because if we
can understand
how exercise can reduce the risk of
cancer then it should help us have a
better understanding of cancer biology
in addition it could also lead to the
rise of different potential
future therapeutics moreover it can help
to validate our understanding of the
benefits of exercise towards cancer
prevention
reinforcing the use of exercise in
addition to current therapeutic
strategies
so what actually is cancer well cancer
is best thought as
uncontrollable cell growth basically a
cell that just keeps on dividing even
when it shouldn't
that can result in the formation of
tumours a good way of understanding
cancer
are through the different hallmarks of
cancer described by hannah hannah and
weinberg
and if you want me to make a video on
that do let me know because
i have been considering it for a while
anyway the reason i bring
the hallmarks up is because it's a
useful framework to use to understand
how exercise
might be implicating the different
hallmarks of cancer
the hallmark that we're going to focus
on in this video is a fading immune
destruction
and effectively this describes how
cancer cells
are able to avoid getting destroyed and
removed and killed
by different immune cells within your
body and one way that it's thought that
tumors can evade immune destruction
is by actually suppressing the activity
of different immune cells
and so you may have heard of
immunotherapy which is effectively a
therapy that can block
different receptors to stop the tumor
cells from inhibiting these different
immune cells
and so the reason i bring this up is
because there's evidence to support that
the anti-tumor benefits of exercise
could be mediated through while at least
partially mediated through the immune
response
key players in this immune response are
the natural killer cells
which as you can guess by their name
they can recognize and kill
tumor cells and so interestingly a study
that came out in 2016
showed that tumor-bearing mice that
underwent a six-week
wheel-running intervention actually
induced the mobilization of these
natural killer cells
and increased their infiltration into
the tumours and this infiltration helps
to control
tumor growth but natural killer cells
may not be the only immune cells that
are influenced by exercise
if we now take a look at this recent
elife paper
they looked at how cytotoxic t cells may
be able to mediate
exercise-induced reductions in tumor
growth and so
cytotoxic t-cells which i may otherwise
refer to as
cd8 plus t cells are kind of analogous
to natural killer cells
in that they can identify and eliminate
tumor cells by immunosurveillance
so in this e-life study they had a
tumor-forming mouse model
whereby they had injected mice with
amirine mammary cancer cell line
that induces tumor growth and before and
after this injection
the mice were given access to an
exercise will
on which they typically run around six
kilometers per day
in addition to reducing the tumor volume
compared to non-running controls
the exercise also increased the numbers
of cd8 plus t
cells these cytotoxic t cells that
infiltrated the tumor
and when the authors depleted these cd8
plus t cells
it also reduced the beneficial effects
of exercise
seen on tumor growth and long-term
survival but if we're ever going to be
able to develop
treatment strategies through this
understanding of exercise
benefits on tumor growth then we have to
have a better understanding of how
exactly
are these cytotoxic t cells being
potentially activated
and then recruited into the tumor site
well to understand this better the
authors then looked at the metabolic
profile of plasma after exercise and
what they observed were higher levels
of krebs cycle intermediates such as
citric acid
malic acid and alpha-ketoglutarate
and the other key metabolite being
lactate that rises very rapidly after
exercise
and so the authors then looks at how
these different metabolites can actually
affect the cd8 t
cells and so what you can see in this
figure is that malate succinate
fumarate lactate and alpha ketoglutarate
all increased the levels of the cd8 t
cells that had a low expression of a
receptor known as cd62l
now this receptor is an adhesion
receptor and so having low levels of
that
receptor is associated with greater
migration of these cd8 t
cells suggesting that these metabolites
could potentially be reducing the level
of this receptor
enabling the cd8 cells to circulate and
head towards the tumor
and strikingly lactate was shown to
greatly increase the amount of grand
sign b
and icos expression on these cd8 t
cells and these are both associated with
activated
cd8 plus t cells and help in the killing
of the target cells
and so one of the cool things that they
then did is take cd8 plus t
cells from trained mice that had been
exercising and transferred them to a
tumor-forming mouse model
to assess whether or not these cd8 plus
t-cells that have been trained by
exercise
could help reduce tumor growth and as
you can see in this figure here
mice that were given t cells from the
exercise mice had a better survival rate
than those given t
cells from non-exercising mice okay so
it looks like these cd8 t
cells are showing some impact on tumor
growth but is there an alternative
strategy besides injecting t-cells
that could also possess a similar effect
well that's exactly what they tested
next
mice were given daily doses of 2 grams
per kilogram of sodium lactate
and this was administered for 12 days
before they then inoculated the mice
with some breast cancer cells
after which they then continued this
daily injection of
sodium lactate and as you can see here
as with the exercise
this in this daily injection of sodium
lactate
also reduced the tumor volume and
improve survival rates
so in sum this paper seems to show that
exercise through modulating the
metabolome can result in
the activation of cytotoxic t cells by
decreasing the expression of an adhesion
molecule
and increasing the expression of their
effector proteins
which is likely why there seems to be a
reduction in tumor growth and improved
survival rates
seen in the various different mouse
models they've used here so this data is
interesting but it also raises a number
of questions
firstly can this information be
extrapolated to humans
and is the effect of exercise mediated
through the same
manner secondly how does the type of
exercise influence this result
for example would strength exercise have
a different impact
and lastly would exercise have a similar
benefit
for pediatric cancers and another thing
i thought was worth mentioning is that
this work still doesn't fully understand
the full links between the changes in
the metabolism
and the changes in the expression
profile of these
cytotoxic t cells and so i think it's
particularly interesting
especially with their changes seen in
lactate that lactate was recently shown
to be an epigenetic regulator
and so that could explain these changes
and also alpha ketoglutarate is also
known to influence
epigenetic marks and so those two in
addition to potentially the other
metabolites
could explain how these cytotoxic t
cells are being activated
and so i think it'll be particularly
interesting to see
further information about this and
another interesting fact is that there's
a lot of lactate and yoghurt
anyway the last thing i want to just
briefly mention is
a lot of you have suggested in the
comments that i start a patreon
account and i've been thinking about
this a lot and i
think it could potentially be a nice
idea if i
managed to work out how to upload these
svg files that effectively
share all my drawings for for the
different videos
and so yeah let me know if that's
something of interest and i can properly
set it up
in addition to just having the standard
patreon
anyway i hope you found this study
interesting at least i did
and i hope you've learned something and
as always thanks for listening